dernier sujet est heureusement moins
dramatique celui là puisque s'agit du du
baccalauréat vous avec des professeurs
refusent de rendre les copies du bac qui
sont chargés matic 2 corrigé ça pourrait
entraîner des retards dans la
publication des résultats
jean michel blanquer le ministre de
l'éducation nationale l'a reconnu ce
matin sur rmc minorité de le professeur
très petit autour de 2,2 à 8 5% qui me
navre ne pas donner les copies attend
donc mais très attentif à ce point là je
le regrette parce que ça donne une
mauvaise image d'eux des professeurs
alors que la l'immense majorité des
professeurs a évidemment un grand sens
du service public et veut rendre les
copies attend donc je ne peux pas
exclure permettait d'un fils en voilà et
voici maintenant le point de vue de
frédéric relais elle est ce qu est un
général du syndicat snes fsu
et pour elle le responsable de tous
abbas et le ministre que qui a refusé
d'entendre les gens hostiles à sa
réforme je rappelle que ce blocage fait
suite à un projet de loi porté par jean
michel blanquer de réforme de
l'éducation nationale
pour nous il s'agit bien de défendre
aussi bien les élèves que les personnels
nous ne portons pas là la responsabilité
de ce qui va se passer c'est le ministre
qui en portent l'entière responsabilité
ça fait des mois que les collègues se
sont mobilisés et les quand même très
regrettable que le ministre face à des
mouvements quand même fort est assis
frère si dans le silence et de refus de
d'entendre des revendications frédéric
dabi c'est une forme de prise d'otages
je pense que ça sera perçu comme ça 3 %
des enseignants c'est une minorité s'est
pas négliger dans une logique
d'extrapolation 600 + 3 % qui doit
favoriser le baccalauréat sera vu comme
une prise d'otage parce qu'il ya
toujours un attachement extrêmement fort
des français pour le bac
même s'il accepte son évolution sont
maintenant favorables au contrôle
continu ils ont plutôt soutenu jean
michel bancaire dans sa réforme du lycée
mais bac comme rite initiatique doit pas
être un avis polluée par des événements
des mobilisations d'événements faut
politiser page et aucun jeu aucune
enquête d'opinion là dessus mais quand
on voit l'attachement des français
surtout les sur ce
lee au baccalauréat la question de la
rétention des notes du bac
à mon avis va être extrêmement mal
perçues notamment par des parents voire
par les heene bio bio vous dirigez un
établissement d'enseignement est un
établissement d'enseignement supérieur
privé une école de commerce mais
néanmoins vous êtes surpris par cette
cette action des des professeurs c'est
assez surprenant il liège quand il ya
des choses qui ne se font pas notamment
en france que le général de gaulle on
met pas voltaire on en bastille pas
voltaire on n'est pas les clefs sur la
table on ne se baigne pour burqini
vérifie s'il est je crois qu'on ne prend
pas en otage les deux bacs
voilà mais mon pour citer aussi mon prof
de terminale et bigot qui est tellement
forte et capable de rater le bac je
pense que la pauvre aimants très très
fort aujourd'hui font rater le bac en
fait donc l'enjeu n'est pas non plus
laisser penser qu'on va donc c'est le
moyen de rater le bac ce serait de ne
pas avoir sa copine et s'assure de voir
je trouve que ce qui se passe est
strictement inadmissible inadmissible et
le langage de la déléguée syndicale
convient d'entendre la responsable
syndicale est totalement effarant c'est
pas elle qui organise sa ni ses
camarades syndiqués et le ministre ben
voyons
le principe de responsabilité elle a
entendu parler évidemment que un tabou
nous vous vient de sauter c'est à dire
que 2 ou 3 % des enseignants d'ailleurs
si c'était 25 % ça serait pareil à
limite assurant qu'ils ne soient que
c'est rassurant mais
justement c'est une action de
minoritaires donc encore plus qui se
veut encore plus spectaculaire puisque
ils sont minoritaires mais prendre les
élèves en otage c'est une chose bloquer
quelque chose qui est tout à fait
crucial puisque on le sait très bien le
taux de chômage des jeunes est très
élevé
l'avenir des jeunes n'est pas pris
suffisamment en considération dans ce
pays
ça n'est pas pris au sérieux la
situation d'un étudiant en france est
bien moins enviable qu'en allemagne que
dans les pays scandinaves ou même que
dans certains cas aux états unis
il y à un point de sensibilité extrême
de la société française sur l'avenir de
la jeunesse et c'est là que ses
camarades syndiqués vont frapper
c'est inadmissible c'est aussi l'avis de
73% des internautes qui considère que
oui c'est une forme de prise d'otage que
ce refus des professeurs de rendre les
corrections des 120 mille copies de
j'ajoute dont ils ont la charge et
c'était un des rares points conçu
consensuelle entre les français de
gauche les français de droite les
français du centre le baccalauréat
c'était quelque chose qui nous mettait
tous d'accord eh bien ça aussi on va le
saboter information intéressante de one
shot qui nous dit attention qui dit
retardé note d'hier tard aussi pour les
demandes d'université donc oui c'est une
vraie prise de taille les plus voici
deux points de vue différents celui de
babineau qui nous dit c'est une forme
d'égoïsme
les professeurs concernés sacrifie les
efforts de leurs élèves alors que panda
nous dit il faut se méfier de jean
michel blanquer
il souhaite un modèle semblable à celui
d'où il vient donc du privé il faudra
effectivement jean michel blanquer a été
directeur d'une grande école de commerce
l'essec pour ne par la nouvelle bon il a
aussi été recteur donc là pour le coup
il était en charge de l'enseignement
public votre point de vue alexandre ii
vecchio bon je pense que sur la forme
ils se trompent parce qu'ils se font
taper dessus et on sait pas que c'est
pas très malin procès votre productif
parce que c'est ça donne l'image d'une
profession pas guéri de mai 68 sur les
rails responsable je suis pas sûr que ce
soit la réalité d'ailleurs il se peut
qu'ils défendent le bac c'est là où
où je trouve que le débat est
intéressant parce que le bac ça fait
consensus et merveilleux moi je pense
que michel blanquer rabot devenir une
vache sacrée à droite
alors c'est vrai que c'est le moins
mauvais des ministres qui s'exprime bien
qu'il fait qu'il parle d'autorité etc
mais je trouve que cette réforme du bac
est une mauvaise réforme
le contrôle continu ça va achever les
finalement de l'égalité dans ce pays ce
qui était bien dans le bac c'était ont
passé un examen
si on avait une mention tout le monde a
vu le même bac et ont été sélectionnés
dans les écoles par rapport à ces
résultats là là dans le contrôle continu
moi je pense à moi j'ai fait ma
scolarité au lycée suger à saint denis
j'avais des très bonnes notes mais je
pense que si j'avais le bac avec mention
sur gossip m'aurait dit oui vous êtes
gentil mais on sait comment on note les
élèves dans ces lycées là donc je pense
que pour faire des économies budgétaires
c'est une réforme qui est ni libérale
c'est pas qui veut transformer
l'enseignement privé ni et à tisser
juste technocratique il faut faire des
économies supprimer des épreuves et on
fait ça voilà simplement pour dire que
c'est une mauvaise réforme
je sais qu'à droite c'est ma niveau faut
dire du bien de jean michel laurent
clerc mais il faut aussi essayer le fond
des dossiers on fait ce qu'on veut
croire qu'elle sape
voilà donc voilà après la méthode des
profs et des paniers page méthodes mais
contrairement à ce dernier mot préféré
lancera tout six points de
l'argumentation d'alexandre d'élection
c'est quand même que pour l'accès aux
grandes écoles aux prépas ça fait
longtemps que c'était pull back qui fait
foi c'est quand même le dossier qui
permet de céder 2 est aussi une des
villes qui va dire des amis parce que
noir et grandes écoles c'est vrai on
supprime les incorrections de la
terminale la chanson apparaît assez
promis d'en point de vue malheureusement
c'était pas avec vous merci beaucoup
cette émission est désormais terminée
mais vous retrouvez demain
marie-mai lombard puisque nous
trouverons jeudi pour un nouveau point
de vue merci beaucoup
[Musique]